[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
du 7-8 débat c'est le cheval de bataille
actuelle du gouvernement réformer le
système des retraites le premier
ministre edouard philippe arts annonce
un projet mettant en place un système
dit universel où les droits ce
calculeront par points levée de
boucliers du côté de plusieurs syndicats
mobilisés depuis 56 jours alors que
l'examen du texte est prévu à
l'assemblée nationale le 17 février
prochain pourquoi cette réforme est
aussi quelles sont les raisons des
oppositions qu'elle suscite vers quel
système de retraite se dirige-t-on c'est
le débat du mois et pour en parler trois
invités avec moi en plateau pierre lux
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le référent
départemental de la république en marge
des civils le parti présidentiel sonia
porot bonsoir bon ça et vous êtes là dès
la secrétaire pardon départemental de la
cgt 60,18 la cgt qui est mobilisé 1
contre cette réforme des retraites en
intersyndicale avec force ouvrière fsu
et solidaires est depuis cinquante six
jours et on précise aussi qu aujourd'hui
on se déroulait une huitième action de
grève interprofessionnelle sa carrière
dit bonsoir bonsoir tout fraîchement élu
en décembre président du medef yvelines
medef c'est bien sûr l'organisation à
qui représente le patronat merci à vous
trois d'être en plateau avec nous je
précise également que florence granger
député des yvelines devait être des
nôtres ce soir florence contenu et qui a
été retenue en commission spéciale sur
cette réforme des retraites justement
ennahda dont elle a duck donc annulé sa
présence dans l'émission regardons pour
commencer ce projet de loi ce que dit ce
projet de loi dans les grandes lignes
ont été présentées par edouard philippe
fin décembre vendredi dernier le texte a
été présenté et validé en conseil des
ministres dans les principales lignes
vous les connaissez trois choses à
retenir est la fonte da42 régimes
spéciaux actuel en un seul nommé système
universel dans ce régime les droits ne
seront plus calculée au nombre de
trimestres validés mais grâce un système
de points chaque heure cotisé permettra
d'acquérir des points dont la valeur
reste encore à définir
enfin dernière chose à mettre à la forme
interrogative l'instant l'instauration
d'un âge dit d' équilibre à 64 ans une
sorte de bonus
malus sur sa pension si on part avant ou
pas après cet âge l'âge légal de la
retraite reste lui fixé à 62 ans et je
précise d'ailleurs que cette question
d'âge à déquilibre doit être encore
tranché le premier ministre edouard
philippe qu'on voit qu'à partir de
demain les partenaires sociaux pour une
conférence de financement l'objectif
c'est de trouver des solutions
alternatives pour garantir les
équilibres financiers de cette réforme
bâle l'introduction est posée pour ce
débat perdu je me tourne vers vous pour
commencer pourquoi cette réforme était
l'un des dossiers phares à traiter pour
le gouvernement cette réforme de galles
est au coeur du projet présidentiel de
manuel macron en 2017 les françaises
sont exprimés en faveur de en sa faveur
aux élections présidentielles et entre
autres c'est une certitude pour défendre
pour qu'ils puissent défendre ce projet
qui procède de justice et de lisibilité
de la caravelle choqué du côté du medef
quelle position face à ce texte qui se
prépare bah écoute et sincèrement nous
ne tire pas demandeurs d'un tel d'état
de réformes
maintenant il est là il faut il faut
faire avec nous avons deux conditions la
première condition c'est établir
l'équilibré du système et surtout ne pas
avoir un surcoût de travail et
l'équilibré du système
il en sera question au travers cette
conférence sur le financement dont on
aura l'occasion de reparler
tout à leur réforme qui suscite bien sûr
je les dix des oppositions 56 jours
cinquante sixième jour de grève contre
la réforme des retraites sonia porot
pourquoi cette opposition ont calé les
motifs de votre opposition ils sont ils
sont nombreux les motifs d'abord il
serait peut-être bien que emmanuel
macron se souviennent qu'il a été élu en
grande partie par un vote anti fasciste
et pas uniquement par adhésion à son
projet
de réformes cette réforme des retraites
par points elle vient réellement mettre
à mal notre système de sécurité sociale
est énormément d'éléments de de
solidarité bien sûr qu'il ya des
améliorations à apporter au système
actuel de retraite pour prendre en
compte la pénibilité pour prendre en
compte le fait que les carrières sont
plus morcelé aujourd'hui mais on passe
d'un système solidaire à prestations
définies où on sait combien on va
toucher et après on regarde comment
trouver les ressources et on a des
propositions à ce niveau là un système
par points dans une incertitude du coup
sur la valeur du point
quand on l'acquiert et au moment de
liquider sa retraite et à cotisations
définies donc on avale à une somme
globale et si le nombre de retraités
augmente et ben il va falloir diminuer
les pensions parce que le budget ne
bouge pas inscrire dans le système
actuel c'est le conseil d'orientation
des retraites qu'il a estimé ainsi une
instance indépendante
ils estimaient qu'entre 8 et 10 7
milliards de déficit il y aurait 8 à
10,7 milliards de déficit en 2025 si on
reste dans le système actuel des
retraites il faut quand même modifier
certaines choses vous étiez pas contre
une réforme mais pas dans ces termes là
papa papa dans ces termes et principales
réformes c'est déjà de trouver des
ressources supplémentaires au fil au fil
des années un certain nombre
d'exonérations de cotisations sociales
ont été ont été faites notamment sur les
bas salaires ce qui est du coup fait des
trappes à bas salaires donc ça ferait
des ressources supplémentaires
on estime que si on avait une égalité
salariale réelle effective entre les
femmes et les hommes ça ramènerait
également plusieurs milliards de
recettes à l'ensemble des caisses de
sécurité sociale donc pour financer les
retraites il y à il y a des tas de
solutions là on allait poser aussi la
question des viennois peut-être une
réaction furieuse parce que l'on vient
d'entendre
oui beaucoup de réactions forcément mais
sur l'essentiel
il ya des solutions de financement
mais pour l'instant on attend justement
qui s'est porté un saut les propos de
gouvernement pour la conférence de
financement on a parlé de réserve
faramineuses qui sont loin d'être
suffisantes on a parlé de maintenir au
delà de 2024 les les prélèvements de la
crds et une partie et prélèvements de la
csg pour participer au remboursement de
2 ans au financement de la retraite mais
on est très très loin en termes de
volume de la dette qui va s'accumuler et
du déficit qu'on va voir dans les années
à venir par les oem de 8 à 17 milliards
d'euros en 2025
d'ici 2025 avec les 7 milliards c'est
l'équivalent c'est plus que l'équivalent
du budget de misère de christie's par
exemple c'est vraiment une somme
faramineuse
on peut faire le choix soit d'employer
ces prélèvements obligatoires à
rembourser va financer la retraite en
remplissant une baignoire qui se remplit
avec le temps ou alors on peut essayer
d'être un peu plus ambitieux est de
refonder un système qui soit pérenne sur
le long terme
le gouvernement fait ce choix la suite
du débat dans un instant d'abord ne
savent où aller a rencontré à quelques
yvelinois pour voir ce qu'il pensait de
ce projet de réforme
les propos sont collectées par patrick
jacques de dixmude et jacques brun moi
je suis pour qu'il soit équilibré à mme
pieper les types de retraites non il
faut pas y toucher parce que je me dis
que les gens bossent toute leur vie pour
assurer leur retraite et donc bénéficier
qu'un boss plus donc je suis pour ce qui
se passe et je les encourage nos matches
que je suis pas avec monsieur de tout
coeur avec c'est parce qu'il y en a qui
sont pas contents parce qu'il est juste
a dit gagné beaucoup d'argent quand il
travaillait et voudrait gagner beaucoup
d'argent quand il sort la retraite mon
point de vue c'est qu'il faut qu'on
change les choses de toute façon et
tant qu'on met pas les choses en place
et d'un peut pas s'avancer fonctionné ou
pas monde sait qu'on le devient de plus
en plus vieux la preuve c'est que
celui-là
et puis qu'il ya de moins en moins de
jeunes pour payer des retraites
donc c'est certain que ça peut pas
continuer tel que c'est maintenant à
cette réforme va aller comme elle est
important que je trouve elle est
importante pour pouvoir justement faire
avancer le système est
que tout le monde soit revenu est plus
ou moins à égalité les habits collectées
qui ne représente qu'un échantillon de
personnes et on a entendu qu'ils sont
plutôt favorables à un changement du
système actuel mais comment réformer
justement quelques pistes est-ce que ce
qui est pro ce qui est proposé par le
gouvernement vous satisfait entièrement
aujourd'hui du côté du medef
non disons qu'il ya beaucoup de flou et
le vrai problème de cette réforme c'est
ça c'est qu'il ya eu deux années de
négociations ou de discussions
le medef en général lorsqu'il a été
consultée pendant ces deux années
il n'y avait jamais des réponses
précises les premières précisions sont
arrivés dès que le premier ministre
avait pris le dossier en main
donc ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point j'ai entendu dire le
représente le rm dire qu'il allait
toucher aux réserves qui ont été
accumulées particulièrement par les
régimes du secteur privé et des
indépendants nous cette démarche elle
nous convient pas pourquoi une réserve
en général il est fait pour les coups
durs eu un écroulement subi de la
croissance
un trou d'air il faut avoir des réserves
pour pouvoir je dirais y répondre et
maintenir les retraites d'aider des gens
en retraite donc c'est c'est vrai c'est
le flou les propositions qui sont faites
aujourd'hui
bon nous avons jusqu'à fin avril avec
les partenaires sociaux pour trouver des
solutions sommes tout à fait ouverts
on reviendra sur lequel envoyé dans un
instant voilà aujourd'hui il ya quand
même je dirais beaucoup de tension les
positions se durcissent
donc nous on dit voilà il faut aller les
discussions fallait négociations faut
trouver des pistes
il ya des choses sur lesquelles il faut
être prudent il faut être mesuré les
réserves ces deux réserves
le coût du travail attention aujourd'hui
des entreprises créent de l'emploi
parce que c'est vrai la cgt parle de
baisse de ca de charges salariales etc
notamment le cic qui parfois décrié le
sait se créer de l'emploi il faut savoir
aujourd'hui les emplois qui sont créés
la france crée des emplois
c'est grâce et c'est un logement qui
permettent aux entreprises de retrouver
de la compétitivité de remporter des
marchés remplir les carnets de commandes
et je dirais embauché pour pour
pour répondre à cette demande donc voilà
comment réformer justement sonia porot
on l'a compris mais pas totalement une
contre une réforme des retraites mais
comment faut il former pas du tout pas
du tout celle là nous on veut préserver
le système de sécurité sociale dont le
principe est extrêmement ambitieux qui
est de pouvoir garantir les salariés et
plus généralement la population des
aléas de la vie voilà de différents
risques la vieillesse la maternité la
maladie l'accident du travail donc ça
c'est très ambitieux et parler de régime
de rendre le régime plus pérenne quand
par exemple les revenus au dessus de
10000 euros
non vraiment les pas vrai a même un
cadre moyen qui fait 45 heures par
semaine y gagnent en général 4 5000
euros maximum
donc les très hauts revenus auront un
plafonnement pour leurs cotisations donc
c'est c'est à nouveau un cadeau aux
entreprises puisqu'elle ne cotiseront
plus et cdc des ressources moment donc
je vois pas du tout où ces pérenne et si
autant de salariés et également de
nombreux travailleurs rue berri zay et
même les les professions libérales se
mobilisent contre ce projet de loi et
c'est quand même une mobilisation
historique c'est qui voit bien qu'on met
à mal ce système solidaire qu'on met à
mal
également parce que c'est aussi dans
beaucoup de revendications les services
publics et que aujourd'hui avec
l'intensification du travail les
inaptitudes les maladies
professionnelles qui augmente les gens
ne se voit pas va continuer à travailler
plus longtemps dans les conditions dans
les conditions actuelles donc c'est
cette cette colère et ce refus il doit
être entendu régime plus pérenne pire
luce c'est aussi un régime plus
égalitaire que souhaite mettre en place
le gouvernement c'est en tout cas ce qui
est avancé par le gouvernement juste
pour venir se dégrade et du medef
évidemment il l'utilisation des réserves
les pas du tout dans le conte veut
défendre
c'est ce qui a été proposé par certains
opposants notamment à lak pilot
mais ce serait insuffisant en plus
juridiquement un peu un peu compliqué
d'aller piquer dans les régimes
complémentaires pour abonder un régime
universel non c'est pas du tout ce qu'on
ce qu'on défend non nous ce qu'on
défense et c'est cette réforme qui
effectivement est plus je parlais plus
de justice plus tôt que d'égalité parce
que on veut un régime universel
ça veut pas dire un régime uniforme pour
tout le monde de la même façon
pourquoi parce que justement on prend en
charge aussi on prend en compte le
travail plus pénible travail de nuit les
carrières extrêmement h et jusqu'à
maintenant si vous travaillez moins de
150 heures pendant un trimestre ça
compte pour du beurre dans votre dans
votre retraite donc quelqu'un qui a un
temps très partiel par exemple est
extrêmement handicapés par le système
actuel le calendrier de cette réforme le
voici
si la réflexion a duré deux ans cela va
s'accélérer désormais le travail du
texte le de loi a commencé depuis hier
soir en commission parlementaire six
jours de travail sont prévus le débat le
début de l'examen en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale est prévue le 17
février deux projets de loi un organique
l'autre ordinaires seront présentés le
vote solennel est prévu le 3 mars avant
une trêve parlementaire pour les
élections municipales puis viendra l
examen du texte au sénat à partir de fin
avril l'adoption définitive de la
réforme est prévue cette année et sa
mise en vigueur total en 2025 après
l'entrée dans le nouveau système des
cotisants est née après 1975 alors il
reste tout de même des questions à
trancher on a parlé de cette question du
financement de l' équilibre de de cette
réforme et aussi la valeur du point qui
reste à trancher est ce qu'on va pas
trop vite
pyrrhus dans dance est ce calendrier de
la réforme des retraites alors que
craignent pour sa vie à 8,2 et forment
ces dernières années qui ont précédé
celle ci et on est tout à fait dans les
temps en termes de temps parlementaire
et on est largement plus large en plus
loin dans l'étude d'impact
on va aussi l'argent plus loin dans les
concertations qui ont eu lieu auparavant
que dans n'importe quel autre réforme
donc je pense que
non il n'y a pas de précipitation après
il faut je pense prendre le problème à
bras le corps et entamé ce travail
parlementaire qui est important qui
amènera probablement le texte mais c'est
toute la beauté de nos démocraties aussi
de pouvoir travailler sur ce texte via
nos députés et les sénateurs
je vois réalisé sagna pour vous n'êtes
pas d'accord oui moi ça m'a vraiment ça
me met en colère de ce que ce que
j'entends mais même le medef reconnaît
qu' il n'y a pas une réponse dans les
dents les nez dans les concertations
parce que c'est pas ça des des
négociations j'entends parler de régime
de régimes plus juste quand les salariés
à temps partiel quand les salariés qui
sont au chômage
on prend l'ensemble de leur carrière les
salaires sur toute leur carrière pour
calculer leur leurs droits à la retraite
a évidemment que le système des points
ça ne ce n'est pas du tout plus juste
est parti les salariés des très petites
entreprises qui sont calmes un quart du
salariat yvelinois dans le privé sont
particulièrement touchés les femmes sont
particulièrement touchées dans les très
petites entreprises elles sont 1 41% à
être à temps à temps partiel enfin c'est
vraiment et tout ce qui était mécanismes
de solidarité intégré à la caisse
d'assurance vieillesse ou on accorder
des trimestres supplémentaires pour
pouvoir partir plus tôt donc savez pas
vous financier là on va compenser en
donnant peut-être quelques points en
plus mais c'est c'est très très flou
tous ceux qui sont au chômage non
indemnisé est basse et beaucoup n'ont
pas ce qu'on a aussi réformer
l'assurance chômage
et là aussi ça va toucher tous les
contrats précaires ceux qui alterne des
périodes courtes d'emploi et chômage
en vigueur depuis le 1er novembre donc
enfin tout ça non n'est pas on n'est pas
dans un système plus juste on est parent
un nivellement par le bas et c'est pas
du tout ni ce que nie ce que veulent les
organisations syndicales opposés au
projet ni ni ce que souhaitent les
salariés sur le calendrier
zachary hardy va écouter ça n'aurait
jamais plus de riz sont habitués sont
étudiants s'il faut effectivement rendre
quelque chose en fin avril on est on est
capable l'essentiel c'est que les
interlocuteurs soient prêts à des
compromis
je voudrais apporter quelques précisions
le plafonnement de courson qui est
normalement privé par l'état sur les
hausses sur les hauts salaires
c'est pas une d'un plafonnement des
cotisations pas du tout il ya un
prélèvement supplémentaire de 2 %
plafonné à 2 % qui sera versé à la
caisse des retraites sans que les les
hauts salaires bénéficient d'un avantage
supplémentaire pendant pour le rhin pour
leur retraite
je voudrais dire aussi que il y a quand
même des choses qui manquent
d'abord une étude d'impact une étude
d'impact est importante pour parler de
financement et voir comment ça coûterait
donc là on va lancer des discussions sur
le financement dont l'apa d'étude
d'impact ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point on sait pas comment ça
contrer la montée en charge du système
on ne sait pas autre point important la
dotation de l'état à la participation
d'états elle va être plus faire de
demain dans le cadre de cette de ce
régime de retraite
au point qu'aujourd'hui elle va être au
niveau imaginons qu'elle soit à 28 % au
même niveau que la codi les cotisations
du régime privé des salariés du privé et
les indépendants et bien il manquerait
dans le système 30 milliards on va les
chercher ou en tout cas je crains fort
qu'on aille chercher encore une fois
dont les poches du secteur privé ou des
entreprises qui sont mises à
contribution
régulièrement donc tous ces petits
points là il va falloir quand même qu'on
prenne le temps dont parlait et que s'il
faut rendre quelque chose d'ici fin
avril
on s'y emploie on en parle dans un
centre cette conférence sur le
financement une réaction sur certaines
réactions sur les propos de l'affront
temps la sécrité match je ne ferai pas
accepter qu'on dise simplement
sans argumenter plus concrètement les
femmes vont s'offrir et travailleurs à
temps partiel ou en souffrir en fait
actuellement le la réforme contient
énormément de mesures en faveur de ces
publics là quand vous prenez en compte
par exemple les enfants dès le premier
enfant sans avoir à attendre le
troisième enfant pour bénéficier d'une
bonification
quand vous prendre consent % des arrêts
maladie des arrêts maladie congés manar
compte dans les calculs de droite dans
le calcul des droits
j'entends encore cet argument comme quoi
le fait de prendre en compte toute la
carrière serait désavantageux non c'est
faux ce serait vrai si on restait sur un
système où on prendrait quelques curés à
pension à partir du du moyenne des tous
les salaires de la carrière ce que c'est
faux là on prend
nous pensions qui sera calculé j'ai
envie de dire mathématiquement une
multiplication à partir du nombre de
points accumulés tout au long de la
carrière fois un coefficient et ça
donnera la pension donc effectivement
sont tranquilles 25 années ça sera
vraiment vraiment dommageable
il faut prendre toute la carrière la
preuve la moindre heures travaillées
d'helmand où fait un job étudiant qui
est un contrat de travail la moindre
heures travaillées rapportera des points
et qui y seront valorisés à la fin de
votre carrière
on peut pas dire que ça pas bénéficier
aux personnes qui travaillent peu ou qui
ont des carrières accès au contraire ce
sont les premiers bénéficiaires puissent
qu'ils cotiseront ils travailleront pour
pour quelque chose
alors que à l'heure actuelle beaucoup de
personnes travaillent pour rien on va
aborder la question de la conférence sur
le financement il nous reste environ six
minutes dans ce débat une conférence sur
le financement qui va débuter à partir
de demain jeudi 30 janvier au conseil
économique social et environnemental et
partenaires sociaux vont devoir plancher
sur l' équilibre financier du futur
système de retraite essayez par exemple
de faire sans l'âge pivot
le doute avait plané sonia porot sur la
participation ou non de la cgt philippe
martinez le secrétaire général a bien
confirmé qu'il participerait à cette
conférence en tout cas pour son début
pourquoi ils participer
qu'est ce que vous en attendez de cette
conférence on espère déjà faire entendre
mais ça veut dire faire prendre en
compte et que les lignes les lignes
bougent et qu'on entende ce que vivent
aujourd'hui les salariés
voilà donc on va faire entendre ses
propositions là et on espère surtout que
on ne peut pas faire une réforme des
retraites on part tant que de questions
de questions financières
moi je ne supporte pas l'expression coup
du coût du travail le travail c'est
c'est une richesse c'est ce qui crée
c'est ce qu'ils créent les richesses et
est ce qui coûte aujourd'hui c'est le
capital parce que la courbe entre
l'augmentation des salaires ce qui est
versé pour les salaires et ce qui est
versé aux actionnaires
elle est en train de diverger de plus en
plus donc on verse de plus en plus aux
actionnaires de moins en moins aux
salariés ou pour investir pour améliorer
les conditions de travail et encore une
fois dans les propositions qu'on a tous
les critères de pénibilité y en a quatre
qui ont été retirées par par emmanuel
macron dont le port de charges lourdes
l'exposition aux risques chimiques et
aujourd'hui une partie importante des
gens quand ils partent à la retraite
sont en longue maladie sont en
inaptitude sont au chômage
donc la question elle est peut-être pas
tellement de comme on pousse les gens à
travailler plus et comme on travaille
mieux - dans meilleures conditions et
comment on travaille tous une question à
vous poser je la poserai aussi à asa
qu'à regarder ce que le compromis est
possible entre les syndicats et le
patronat justement au cours de cette
conférence sur le sur le financement bas
sur sur les critères de pénibilité par
exemple
voilà évidemment on n'est pas on n'est
pas en accord parce que la pénibilité
pour nous à la cgt c'est vraiment ce
qu'on ne peut pas supprimer ce qu'on ne
peut pas améliorer
voilà que dans certains métiers on sera
obligé de travailler de nuit et ben
voilà ça il faut il faut effectivement
le prendre en compte et les hôpitaux
doivent tourner la nuit par contre il ya
d'autres critères ou si on améliore les
conditions de travail si on réduit
l'intensité trahissent il ya
suffisamment d'emplois on peut très
largement faire baisser la pénibilité et
du coup on n'a plus à la prendre en
compte
après parce qu'on travaille dans de
meilleures conditions vous n'êtes qu'à
regarder le compromis sur cette
conférence ce que vous en attendez
beaucoup en tout cas de cette confiance
qui va s'étaler vous l'avez dit jusqu'à
la fin avril
bah écoutez il y a effectivement des
sujets à discuter la pénibilité par
exemple la pénibilité il ya des choses
qui vont pas par exemple quand il y
avait la pénibilité sur les conditions
de chaleur
nous avons décollé qui sont à cayenne où
la température moyenne varie de 32 à 36
degrés comme en fait tous ces gens là
seront dans la pénibilité
il ya des choses qui vont pas il faut
ramener un peu de raison et surtout il
faut éviter éviter de rendre de travail
extrêmement compliqué en france certains
de pénibilité faut les reconnaître et
sur un couvreur maçon certaines charges
ou des fous il faut regarder c'est
problématique là mais maintenant nous ne
sont pas si vous voulez fermer à tout
mais nous ne sont pas aussi ouvert sur
différentes des demandes qui sont un peu
et ici tiens regarde porter perdu sur
cette conférence c'est ce que vous
pensez qu'on pourra trouver une solution
alternative à à l'âge des équilibres en
tout cas cette mesure pour l'instant est
émise en suspens par le premier ministre
sept musées et les mises en suspens ne
soit pénibilité c'est important et
gouvernement le
montre aussi dans le projet qu'il
propose avec une meilleure prise en
compte de cette pénibilité les critères
qui n'ont pas disparu qui n'ont pas été
supprimés ils ont été transférés au mali
professionnelle c'est à dire que on ne
le tient on ne prend pas en compte le
fait que personnalité exploser une
charge de l'eau pendant toute sa vie
mais si elle a des dommages physiques
dans la fin de sa carrière ça pourrait
être pris comme maladie professionnelle
donc on parle travail de nuit il sait
bien on est d'accord effectivement
quelqu'un qui travaille de nuit ces
quelques quelque chose de
particulièrement pénible et il faut
qu'on puisse d'offrir un système de
retraite
c'est ce qui est prévu qui lui
permettent sur la fin de sa carrière de
travailler moi tout en conservant un
niveau de revenu
un niveau de revenus suffisants et sur
la confiance de financement je fais
confiance en la les syndicats les
représentants des salariés et des
travailleurs en général des entreprises
pour trouver un terrain d'entente
le premier ministre garde à portée de
main la solution de la clio qui a été
étudiée qui a été dans l'étude d'impact
a été fait
l'étude d'impact pour le projet de loi
fait mille pages donc il ya dedans
largement de quoi vérifier sur le long
terme parce que ça peut provoquer et il
faudrait pas qu'on prenne une autre
solution ce prétexte d'un accord fait à
la va vite et sur lesquels effectivement
on n'aurait pas fait d'études
approfondies donc les syndicats disent
avoir d'autres solutions très bien les 6
12 ans puisqu'on discutons-en et qui
nous est présente
cette conférence va durer je le disais
jusqu'à la fin avril on pourrait encore
débattre un bien sûr pendant plusieurs
minutes mais ce débat arrive déjà à sa
fin merci à vous trois aides est revenue
en plateau pour y participer le débat
qui reviendra après une période
électorale les élections municipales qui
se déroule en mars prochain belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]